good morning Billy nation today's
message is don't stop working over to
you bill burr ing annoying people I
don't know why not like the whole crowd
obviously because then I'd be bombing
but there's a segment like that's what
I'm having the most fun when like 80% of
the crowd is loving it and then there's
that 20% just going like like you know
just looking around like how are you
laughing at this like and I people don't
notice sometimes I can see them and if I
can figure out what they're reacting to
it becomes like a game to see like if I
can get them to yell at me or get up and
start to leave you know
I mean other than that cuz one wants you
there's a danger once you put together
an hour that works you know is you you
can just stop working you know and then
you know and just joke I'll just show up
I'll two can drink all night you know
I'll walk my way through the radio I'll
just keep doing this hour that I have
memorized and I'll be thinking about
doing my taxes as I'm doing my jokes and
but then what happens is is everybody
else catches up with you and the next
thing you know you're that guy on stage
going you know what's up with the Carter
Administration this is crazy
and you become that guy too many
entrepreneurs get bored of their
businesses and they fail too many
entrepreneurs let the success any
success that they had in the past be
chains from them achieving more it
happens so often it's crazy how much
this happens at the start of being an
entrepreneur we leave our jobs we leave
what most people are doing to go off
into our own thing to be crazy to be
wild to have our own business at our own
rules be your own boss right that's how
we start off and then you start to get
some customers then you start to make a
little bit of money maybe not huge money
but maybe you have made huge money but
you said to make a little bit of money
and what happens so often to so many
entrepreneurs is once you start making a
little bit once you find the thing that
you've made some money on
then that's all you do and you stop
innovating and you stop growing and you
stop building and you just focus on this
one thing and that is death for an
entrepreneur because we love creating
new stuff we love exploring we love
trying out new things and as you grow
and you evolve and change as a human
being what you need to do is bring that
to your business where too many
entrepreneurs get bored or their
companies because at the start they love
it because it's a reflection of who they
are what they want to do and then they
start building it they grow and evolve
as a human being but they don't grow and
evolve their business their business a
stock doing what they wanted to do a
couple years ago like what Evan loves
doing five years ago is not the same
thing as what Evan loves doing now and
so as I build and grow as a human being
I bring that to my business I try new
things I like to explore and if you find
yourself really getting bored than what
you need to do is pass on some of that
business somebody else what I try to do
in my companies I build up a business to
the point where I can either hand it off
to somebody else or I drop it most
projects that I start by the way don't
work most of the new things that I put
out don't work most of the new series
we've created for the YouTube channels
they don't work we've cut more series
for this YouTube channel than most
people ever create because it didn't
work a combination of like maybe I'm not
as passionate about it anymore and you
guys didn't like it either and so we
dropped it that's okay
that's good and so most of the things
that I tried to start I'll put my own
energy and effort into just me when I
started the YouTube channel was just me
it was just me and no lights and no
microphone and a really bad camera was
just me and I built it to the point
where I was able to make some money off
of it and then I hired somebody and then
I had another person I had another
person built up the team but most
projects for me don't even go that way
most projects I try build it up and it
doesn't get anywhere and so I drop it
move on
than else but that experimentation is
key
you can't stop working you can't stop
building
you can't stop evolving in your company
if you are bored right now most
entrepreneurs look to that I need to
sell this business and go do something
else it's because you've let it get so
far apart the person that you were when
you started the business and the person
that you've now become and you haven't
brought your business with you you've
gotten so far apart that you're ready to
leave it and do something else find a
way to inject the new self into your
business and make it catch up with you
constantly and if there are things that
you don't enjoy anymore and you don't
want to do but still add a lot of value
and still make money great hire somebody
on your team who loves doing that work
and give it to them and if you can't
afford to hire somebody to do it
then stop kill that project because it's
not financially worth it like if you're
doing projects that is not making enough
money to hire somebody else to do and
you don't want to do it anymore then
just drop it and start working on the
work that you love because that's where
you're gonna come alive that's we're
gonna create magic you need to evolve
with your business look at a great bein
like the Beatles may be the greatest
band of all time their first album was
not the same as a second album was not
the same other third album the reason
why they had so much sustainability was
because they evolved their business as
they evolved as human beings if they
stuck to just doing the same album every
time they would be a 1 album wonder
nobody would pay attention to them
anymore
but as they grew and as they evolved
their business grew and evolved around
them and so who do you want to be you
want to be the Beatles I do you want to
be a one-hit wonder time to decide so
the question today today is how curious
how have you evolved your business with
you I'm curious from when you started
your business to where you are now how
have you grown and how have you
introduced new things into your company
I'm really curious to find out please
leave it down the comments below and
we'll join in the discussion I also want
to give a quick shout out to Stephen
Watson Stephen thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book your one
word it really really really means a lot
to me and I hope you're enjoying it
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you I hope
to believe in yourself and whatever your
one where it is much love and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning for another
shot of espresso
I believe nation thank you so much for
watching if you want to learn more about
this subject get a little bit deeper on
it I'm gonna share some extra bonus
clips that I hope you'll enjoy why do
you still care enough to keep you're at
a point in your life where you could go
back you could do your month in Vegas
and Florence Henderson could open up and
you could go and hit a couple of balls
and then some pinball why do you still
care so much well I'm not comparing
myself to any of these people believe me
but you wouldn't say to Picasso why are
you gonna put those brushes down get rid
of the canvas you've done it I'm an
entertainer first and foremost but
there's art involved here and an artist
has an obligation to be on route to be
going somewhere there's a journey
involved here and you don't know where
it is and that's the fun so you're
always going to be seeking and looking
and going and trying to challenge
yourself so without sitting around
thinking of that a lot
it drives you in it and it keeps you
trying to be fresh trying to be new
trying to call on yourself calling
yourself a little more and I think you
know some of that is just that the the
well first of all if you do very well
and you make a lot of money when you
look back on your experiences and you
know running a company or starting a
company and and and and and there's
almost a kind of disbelief in like how
did I really go through that I really
deal with all of that pain and headache
and hassle and and intensity and and
that's this is one of the reasons why
people who are founders are often so
bonded together like people who have
gone to war they they you know they'll
never they'll never they'll never forget
those experiences but to get up and do
that again over and over again knowing
full well each time exactly what you're
in what's in store for you I think that
is that is more rare and it definitely
requires that you're not willing to rest
on your laurels I can't sit back and say
okay well I founded a bunch of companies
they've they've been tremendously
successful
therefore all my companies are going to
be successful I
to be as paranoid and as and as edgy
about each new company